you saw in the case of Tucker Carlson
one of the things that people I think
weren't fully aware of Tucker's still
getting at least and again I don't have
any inside information I'm not but from
all reports Tucker's getting paid the
Network's just keeping him off the air
and I think that people miss that
sometimes where you take 25 mil to be
off the air I take five
all right we are live in the local
Studio I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report and joining me is the former
White House Press Secretary president
Donald Trump a former host at Newsmax TV
and host of the uh unnamed new podcast
that I can't say is the Sean Spicer show
it could be Spicer and something or
spicier or something something I'll be
too determined thanks for having me it
is good to be with you first off just
look at the two of us like we should be
hosting a show together all right deal
that's it we settled it maybe that's the
new show we really really set this up um
what's the deal man you left news max
you're a free agent you want it to be
free I enjoyed doing your show well I'd
love to have you you can still this is
the beautiful part about it uh look I
think in this age that we're in right
now and I I count you as a mentor and
someone that blazed a trail you look at
bongino and back uh what Megan Kelly's
done Liz wheeler
the ability to go out and not be
constrained by a network and don't get
me wrong I'm not
disparaging I mean they have a role and
but it's a set time for a certain amount
of minutes
um I looked at the upcoming cycle
president Trump's obviously the front
runner in the Pres in the in the
Republican nomination I spent six years
at the RNC uh last cycle as Chief
strategist two presidential Cycles 10
members of Congress countless campaigns
and I thought I have something to add
and I don't know that I want to be
constrained by a network and was it just
technical constrainment like meaning
time like a lot of times when I do cable
shows even when I would do your show
it's like we'd have six minutes let's
say and by minute five now we're getting
going and then they have correct so was
that it or was it more of a Content like
they don't want you talking about
certain things no no no it wasn't that
much to your point it's you have six
minutes to break down a very complex
subject why the rules of the party why
the debate structure is what it is uh it
doesn't lend itself to Six Minutes uh
first and foremost and second maybe you
want to go on for 20 minutes maybe you
want to do some additional videos the
thing that people have to understand is
when you sign a network contract whether
it's Newsmax or fox or ABC they the
trade-off that you're making is I will
restrict what I do to that Network
that's what they're buying from you is
saying you've got a lot of expertise or
Insight we're basically buying it from
you so that you can't go anywhere else
and display that I get that but there
was a point at which I realized the
future is Independent Media the ability
to put stuff out and allow it to go on
different platforms so maybe you want to
put out a tweet obviously Rumble and
YouTube locals there's all these
different ways of getting things out and
you look at the major cable stations
Dave the average age of a viewer is 70
years old now those are a very highly uh
it's a group that votes in a very high
right so it's important but but if I
want to have an influence in the next
generation of Americans who I feel that
I've got something to offer talk about
the ills of the direction of the current
Administration or what have you I
thought is that really where I want to
be in constraint to that if I go uh and
and do something in the Independent
Media field I could still go on Newsmax
I could still go on CNN or Dave rubin's
show or Liz Wheeler's show and and have
a much bigger base to spread the message
and the information that I think I have
so long story short you've been jealous
of me for quite some time very much
mostly the hair it's mostly the hair
killing it in the hair yeah they've done
something to you right so they've done
is it vitamins what are they doing uh
it's a lot of supplements uh you know
all those things that they sell you know
I dial up yeah I mean whatever Seb gork
is selling I got that
you know but uh you know I do want it to
be free I mean yeah I wanted to be free
I wanted to do
um and again and there's a trade-off
that you're making when you are a W-2
employee of a network there are times
when they're saying these are the
subjects we want you to cover or maybe
some substitute we wanted to stay away
from I want to go where I want to go
where I think people need information uh
where I think they're not getting
information and if you think about the
last few years you know the most obvious
being Hunter Biden's laptop not that
that was ever an issue to not talk about
but so many in the Legacy Media suppress
that story and it had an outcome I think
that there are a lot of stories that
don't get attention and it has to do
with why things work how things operate
and that going in this direction gives
me that ability to have that
conversation can you talk a little bit
about how newsrooms operate because I
think for people that watch my show or
they watch some of the guys that you
just mentioned there they watch Tim bull
Megan et cetera et cetera you're just
seeing one person in take in knowledge
take in what's going on on Twitter and
everything else and then I try to
communicate that back to my audience
over let's say an hour or something like
that but in a newsroom it's it's a very
different situation when you have I
don't know how many producers you write
and all that I'm guessing you're gonna
have a slim down staff now I I like a
Slim Trim operation but that's that's
not for everybody well look you have
Network considerations uh so sometimes
they're saying here are the guests that
we want you to get on here are the
subjects we need to get covered a show
is basically broken up to not every show
but most shows are broken up into six
blocks right you do an opening and then
you've got a commercial and then another
segment or a guest and then you've got a
commercial so you got six blocks to to
figure out what you want sometimes there
are subjects that you have to cover
breaking news network mandates guests
that they're requiring you get on books
that they want you to review or or what
have you
um and and so it's a combination and it
depends on the day there is no day where
it's your show I always told people
because I took a lot of view or input
through my website Sean spicer.com they
would email me and say I didn't like
that subject or you know why don't you
do this and I'd say just because it has
my name on the show I don't own it I
mean it's the network could call it any
day and say it's not spiced from company
anymore it's company and Spicer or
whatever they wanted to it's their
Network
um I just work there and you saw in the
case of Tucker Carlson one of the things
that people I think weren't fully aware
of Tucker's still getting at least and
again I don't have any inside
information I'm not but from all reports
Tucker's getting paid the Network's just
keeping him off the air and I think that
people miss that sometimes where you
take 25 mil to be off the air I take
five I mean you know I don't say sure I
would take 25 million off the air I
think Tucker's in a very different
situation he wants to have the influence
and I I mean I jokingly say that because
I think that part of the reason I'm
doing this is because
I I don't you know everybody's got
something I got a brother who knows
everything about sports that's really
not my thing some people are really good
at Art I love politics in the media I
think that based on my 30 years of doing
this I have the ability to translate
what's happening and why why someone
went to a particular place why they gave
the speech at that particular time why
they spent their money in their campaign
in the way that they did or maybe why it
was a mistake that they did something
the way that they did
um having seen it so many times
over the years uh
and I think it's important to bring that
to people because there are too many
times when people are you know if you go
back to the sports metaphor there's a
million times people are arm chat core
armchair quarterbacks and they sit back
there you know what you should thrown
right and you go except the fact there
were five guys rushing them that might
have made it difficult to see that I
think sometimes in politics
what I want to break down is the ability
to say you know I know that might seem
obvious but here's why that's a bad
issue and the most obvious thing I
always tell people this when I was the
assistant U.S trade rep
for a long time people had urged us to
file uh intellectual property case
against China they're stealing our
movies well a lot of people in the
industry didn't want the government to
file the case and you think to yourself
that's pretty counter-intuitive Until
you realize when we finally did file the
case there wasn't a movie from the U.S
shown in China for six months for sensor
reasons right that it was almost like
the industry had factored in the
intellectual property reasons but that's
not right or wrong I'm just saying that
there are sometimes
reasons why things are happening in
government in politics in the media that
might not be as obvious to folks and I
think that because of where I've worked
and what I've done I have the ability to
say let me give you some insight into
that to make you more informed as a
citizen do you think there's any
parallel to any other time in Media or
politics at least in modern times where
it seemed like everything was collapsing
at once like I'm basically of the
opinion at this point if the
administration this current
Administration says anything almost
anything I think it's a complete lie
your former job the White House Press
Secretary I mean Corrine jump here is
doing something remarkable I think that
she is more dishonest than gen saki
that's actually incredible and they have
the media on their side when you were
there the media was against you we've
talked about that we can we can talk
about it further but but my point is
that the media is collapsing and our
political establishment is collapsing
seemingly at the exact same time almost
almost connected to each other actually
but you know and I don't want to bring
this back to obviously part of the
reason I'm here but that's why you've
seen it thank you
but this is why you have flourished damn
bongino's flourish Glenn Beck has
flourished Megan I mean all these people
because people are saying that's not
honest I'm watching it with my eyes yeah
I'm watching people fled over the
southern border and the White House
Press Secretary is like we're we have
this under control and you're like okay
and then I turn on NBC news or the
Washington Post and I see nothing so
where am I going to get somebody to tell
me what's really happening and I think
that's where people are searching out
these things I mean you look I've done
Tim Poole's show twice that guy gets
numbers on a nightly basis live that
most some networks would kill for yeah
because people are saying I'm tired of
being misled lied to uh have stories
suppressed and they're looking and
they're searching for people who have
insight and ideas that they're not
getting anywhere but is it odd to you
that these guys can't course correct I
always say it's like the media doesn't
have to be great I would just prefer
they not be completely
they seem unable like the Titanic they
see the they see the iceberg I often
wondered that myself I'd say why don't
like after the 2016 election I was in
New York City obviously that's where the
Trump headquarters was senior Executives
from NBC called to can we have coffee
can we talk so we we had with this sit
down and they said we're gonna we
realized we missed a lot of this so
we're gonna set up these pop-up bureaus
around America and I'm like so let me
get this straight you're gonna go to
like Cedar Rapids for like a week and
think that like your New York dude is
going to suddenly get in touch with with
all of these farmers and people who
depend on the land and but their their
idea was like it was like a field trip
yeah I mean and there is a complete
utter misunderstanding of and I I think
there was no bigger
to me realization
then when Trump did this town hall in
CNN the other night all of these folks
on the left and in the media
broke down the next day and apologized
Anderson Cooper went off on this rant
but here's the thing that I said you
never watched CNN but but the thing that
I thought was fascinating Walter Shapiro
put out an op-ed that said we should
never do live audiences again and you're
like because why yeah because you didn't
control it remember that audience was
picked hand-picked by CNN but let me go
back to Anderson Cooper he gets on and
does this monologue about how you know
I'm sorry if you were offended now
regardless of whether you like Trump or
not at the end of the day he is
currently the the leading candidate for
the Republican nomination and according
to ABC Washington Post he leads Biden by
seven okay so that means let's call it a
majority of Voters in both the primary
and in the general are supportive of
trump who are you apologizing to if
you're supposed to be a down the middle
media organization in theory you should
be catering to 50 50. that's what CNN
says that they do so why are you
apologizing because what 46 were
offended or upset because they live in a
bubble and I'm convinced that that gets
to the nut of your question they don't
talk to anyone or see anyone that thinks
differently from them so they finish
their afternoon whatever they do after
CNN and then fly by helicopter to The
Hamptons hang around a bunch of people
who think the same way they do fly back
go to some fundraiser or charity event
where everyone talks about the same
things that they do I just don't think
that there's an understanding that
there's another part of the country
other than the one that they live in and
so it's an ignorance that I think is
driving this you think it might have
been a risk to call everybody a big and
a racist for 10 years because then
eventually you really you can't talk to
anybody else in the end right you end up
in that exact situation so I I think for
a lot of these folks
when you look at the parties and
political Playbook has been warning
digestive you know who was spotted at
what it's always the same people at the
same events talking to each other on the
left they never invite anybody on the
right they just and so the the media
folks are talking to a bunch of elected
Democrats and political operatives on
the left so they all hear the same thing
and they think somehow that's just the
prevailing narrative I think that's the
biggest problem right now is that there
is no cross-pollination I say to people
all the time believe me I get yelled at
by democrats uh by folks in the left by
Trump haters so I I see it I hear it I'm
very well aware that a lot of people
don't like the Republican Party
conservative policies Donald Trump but I
think for folks on the left they don't
see the other side they don't think that
there is anybody that supports
conservative policies that wants a
secure border that stands up for Life
those things to them are just that they
don't get it they're they're going I
don't know who who are these people that
you speak of right well a guy like me is
to out there for them I mean I've never
been on CNN ever I've put out two
best-selling books we tried to get on
CNN
but in in you know you know you're a
very reasonable person like you've been
on the left in a way that's a bigger
risk for them right that's the problem
it's a threat yeah right so you talk
about your evolution in your book uh
you've talked about the people that
you've been around the the Outreach I
know in on your show you talk a lot
about the the efforts that you've made
to reach out to Democrats to appear
to to them they don't want you there
they don't want to hear another thing
it's funny you think about like some of
these Sunday shows they have round
tables
they've never had ABC CBS one person
that supports Donald Trump now I think
to myself you may not like him but go
back to the statistics he is the leading
candidate and he is currently either
tied maybe a point or two behind or in
front of Donald I mean of Joe Biden but
it's going to be a close race if he's
the nominee and yet they don't want a
single person on their show to give
people perspective as to what he's doing
or why why because you don't want people
to know let me ask you about the media
strategy of your your former boss Trump
so one of my frustrations with him has
been that he is feeding the very machine
that you're talking about by going on
CNN he's telling you they're the failing
New York Times and failing CNN and I
have no ratings but at the same time
he's empowering that very machine and to
me that's a that's a real problem in
terms of selective pressures I would
rather the machine just die and let's
let's go to the new ground right let's
go to the promised land what do you
think about that I I'm with you on that
I I've never been a big fan
of him
supporting the people who are coming
after him Maggie Haberman doing
interviews with her and he's got a
fixation with some of these Legacy
Outlets particularly the New York Times
because he considers that his hometown
paper still
um I would much rather him put his
efforts in supporting
shows like yours shows like what will be
mine
um why not I I don't because here's the
thing that
so many times people say well you're
just talking to yourself that's not true
if Trump talks to Dave Rubin the New
York Times will write about it NBC will
cover it uh it's just a fact right and
and they will cover this so why not
support the people who are trying to
build up this ecosystem uh of folks on
the right and allow them to be
successful so did you ever give him that
kind of advice when um I tried once and
um I I I I I I was very clear about a
particular right after the election he
was going down to the New York Times
Movie Theater award I was not in favor
of that
he let me know in various dark terms uh
that he really didn't care what I
thought well so your feeling was oh
they're gonna lie about you no matter
what well why are you I also thought why
are we rewarding them this close to
after the election they didn't help us
they hated us and they're not going to
change their position because you go to
them in fact I I thought optically it
looked bad we're you are the
president-elect they come to you you
don't go to them number one number two
why of all the organizations are they at
the top of the list they should be at
the bottom of the list you want to do
them have a bunch of conservative folks
media and have some people that were
treated you fairly
um and then get to them but at the why
are we leading with them
um but you know his view was I can
handle anyone he can and that's it's not
I always viewed it as that's not he he
handled himself I think brilliantly at
the CNN Town Hall it's not a question of
can you handle it but he gave them 3.1
million viewers that night the highest
they beat every other station
and so well I guess he understands that
if he does that for them they'll keep
talking about him right and then he'll
go back to them so that's what I'm
saying it becomes this odd
self-fulfilling prophecy that they'll
both continue right and I think that
that's sort of a problem at this point I
agree and part of the reason that
I I've never supported him doing that
and I still don't is because of that
exact reason I think that the more that
we give them
Credence to go after him he talks to him
that no one treats him fairly I mean he
has sat down for books interviews
um documentaries you name it and and it
always comes out looking poorly on him
no matter what and so why let that
happen because if he goes and talks to
somebody else they'll still cover it so
you'll get your your your thing you're
not going to win them over it's just not
going to happen and I think that's what
you know I think somehow he believes if
he keeps chipping away he has this
businessman mentality and I get it which
is I'm gonna get a deal with you you're
gonna like me and I think people
probably do come away liking him saying
wow he's not what I thought they're not
gonna go back to their editor and say I
tell you what they went really well I'd
like to write something nice about the
guy that's not going to happen talk to
me about your your old job we've talked
about this a bit before but when I watch
you how long was your stand it was
pretty seven months seven months and
then Kaylee no then Sarah Sarah then
Stephanie then Kaylee right
um when I watched the last two saki who
just everything was a lie after lie
after lie and then and then this one
cringe up here I mean it is
extraordinary when you're watching her
you pulling your hair out like how the
hell could it be this bad I get it so
press secretary you have to like so I
was saying this as much as like I I
agree like sake at least was a
professional okay first of all Jen and
just so the audience understands when
when you transition Jack and Josh orange
was very kind to me I wrote about this
in my first book and they they treated
the the transition in a very
professional way and said you know what
we disagree with you but our job is to
make sure you're ready to govern and
that you guys are successful and I'll
never forget that I I give them credit
for being
very professional
um and and how they and helpful because
they were
gen for what it's worth is qualified to
do that job she had served as State
Department spokesman she had been on
several campaigns she'd been with Obama
um you may not like the answers and I
get it and I I don't I accept who cares
couldn't jump here is not qualified to
do the job yeah okay and every single
day we hear it we watch each other she's
a black lesbian for God's sakes what do
you want exactly but that's the point is
that this is the new standard which is
what box can you check not are you
qualified are you experienced can you do
and this isn't like personal she
literally was a field operative before
doing it so she got sent to the
political Opera you know the political
Affairs office I'd say great that makes
sense she was on uh John Edwards
campaign she had done a bunch of races
in New York I get that she just never
dealt with the media before she wasn't
someone who was familiar to them she
doesn't understand the Karen feeding
um and so it would be like somebody
parachuting into you know the political
Affairs job you'd say why are you doing
that they wanted her because she checks
boxes and it's goes every day and the
thing that upsets me more than that is
the way that the White House Press Corps
nods up and down as if what she's saying
is a true and B as if she knows what
she's doing they're complicit in this
and that's the thing is that it I
couldn't get away with things that were
factually true but they would say well
technically you know the North Star was
placed a little I mean they they were
trying to find ways to slice and dice it
with Corinne she blatantly gets up there
and talks about the president's policy
led to a 90 drop in Border Crossing so
that's patently false and yet she gets
away with it
um she talks about the president taking
more questions than shouted questions
than anyone before I mean you could hate
Donald Trump and say there's no question
every day the guy was standing next to
everyone was the propeller went off
taking questions for you know 15-20
minutes a day Joe Biden hasn't talked to
anybody for that long what does that
tell you about the people in that room
at this point I mean they were obviously
oppositional to guys like you they're
always going to be oppositional if
there's a Republican president they're
not oppositional now and she's still
doing a pretty I would say piss poor job
yeah well maybe he's doing exactly
because of it look I think part of it is
remember if you're on the team then
that's all that matters so she's on the
team in several ways right she's she had
been working at MSNBC she uh her partner
works at CNN she is a liberal so she
fits the they're not going to hurt her
because they know that she's got to end
back up at CNN or MSNBC when this is all
done and that's that's what's going to
happen does it ever feel to you like
we're in just The Show Must Go On
version of all of this that's what it
feels like a lot to me like none of it
really works we all kind of know it
doesn't work we know it's all corrupt
I'm talking about politics media the
whole thing but but it sort of has to
continue because if we were to really be
confronted with the reality that none of
it works man it would it would collapse
it's worse it's dangerous way perhaps
it's worse than that
because if you knew how little the
government was prepared for certain
things but also I look at the threat
that China poses at this point I'm happy
they're not prepared for things well
they can only make things worse but you
look at the threat that China poses
um the rise of our debt all of these
things and say it's right there
um I always I get a kick out of this but
there was in in the first
um
uh there was a scene where Dr Evil is
going after Scott evil and he's trying
to kill Austin Powers in that first
Austin Powers movie and he sends him
down to I think be with the sharks and
Scott evil says can't we just he's right
there we can shoot him I have a gun and
Dr Eva says no no no we're gonna put him
in the Shark Tank where he obviously
subsequently escapes and so many times
in government the solution's sitting
right in front of you you could say
can't you just solve that and they go no
no you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna create this commission or we're
gonna create a study and right you're
like you're just punting and I feel like
whether it's the Border
China the debt all of these issues the
government just doesn't want to act and
love them or hate him the thing that I
loved about Trump was that he would look
at something bad a trade deal and I'd
been I mean I joked about it from the
podium but I then the assistant U.S
Trader for under the last three years of
bush and we were told over and over
again well you know this this it's
called being in force this trade
agreement's in force we can't do
anything about it unfortunately we've
all signed our names Trump started to go
I don't really care it's a bad trade
deal we're pulling out of NAFTA and
everyone's like
and what happened we ended up signing
usmca better deal for Wisconsin Dairy
Farmers Alabama automakers over and over
again you go is that that bad we pulled
out of Iran we pulled out I mean like we
did things the Paris climate treatment
and everyone said the the sky is going
to fall
when you're not concerned about the
Muslim Embassy oh my God World War
um and not only that but it went from
not causing World War to the Abraham
Accords which you know allowed for
countries that hadn't talked we have
flights going over places you just came
back from there a few weeks ago where
we we now have things but somebody has
to be willing to say I don't mind
because it it's always been done this
way I'm willing to take a chance and do
it the other way or if it's better and
that's not this is you know this I'm
sorry because I Shameless self-promoter
here but this is why I'm doing what I'm
doing that to explain to people that
there are better ways to do it I watch
president Trump do it I watch the sky
not fall and so you know part of as we
do this
is you know and I
we don't want to bury the lead but part
of the show is we're going to build this
all in local something that you've done
and we're going to have a section where
VIPs can tell me what do we want to hear
what it what are you guys interested in
what do you think we need more of or
less of and how do you want me to
present this or who would be a good
person to bring in or what kind of
expertise and that's the beautiful thing
about doing what I'm doing is that
through the locals Community our VIP
members can be part of this process and
say I want to know more about this why
is the primary and caucus system set up
the way it is why can't we stop the flow
of illegal immigration why is whatever
it is I might not be the best person but
I certainly know who is and that's the
other thing I might you know be able to
call in somebody and say hey I keep
getting questions from our locals
audience that they want to know more
about whatever so let me get you know
Chad Wolfe to come in and explain it
from the homeland security standpoint or
Tom Holmen to come in and talk about
from a border security standpoint but I
think there are things going on to your
point that it feels like we're just
doing something the debt I mean this is
insane what's going on with our debt
every year we keep having the same
conversation and saying we can't talk
about it right now because we don't want
to default but then once we raise the
debt ceiling we forget to have the
conversation and we keep reissuing the
credit card and saying we've raised your
debt limit just please kind of don't
maybe spend as much Biden every day
talks about more spending and we're
supposed to believe that this guy is
going to be concerned about the
long-term debt and debt ceiling is is
the problem with the debt ceiling though
that people just know that they will
just phrase the ceiling so it's just
like yes just keep raising it but I mean
did it did it like a well-known
Economist ever come into the White House
while you were there and be like guys
here's actually the reason why we can't
do this forever you know well because
Trump did it too right but the
difference is and again I don't give
anyone a pass just so we're clear right
but at the end of the day there's a
difference between a worldwide pandemic
where both parties are saying need to
take care of I was not in agreement with
all the spending but then again that's
not my job
um and we're seeing now when we're
clawing back spending it's because no
one thought it through the right way and
there was no accountability
um but the the bigger point is
you know we
no one no one is willing to care like if
you keep saying to folks well the
interest on the debt is going to rise
and it's going to crowd out stuff in
2047 like okay right I mean right let's
we'll figure it out then right it's sort
of like you know when when if you think
back you know a decade ago when we were
doing these loans where there's like
okay we're gonna give you a really low
interest rate but then there's a balloon
payment in 15 years like a little famous
balloon payment like right yeah 15 years
until that balloon payment comes and the
point is we're crowding out
other spending within a couple decades
so we're going to literally have a
conversation with this unfortunately
we're paying so much interest on the
debt that we can't do certain things
what do you think it would take to
actually have serious people again
involved in politics and then media
obviously we're here in Florida you know
my feelings about what's going on here
in Florida and what the governor has
done and everything else
um it seems to be working here it is and
it's working in a couple other red
States but how do you scale that do you
think
um I think Governor DeSantis has done a
great job of going to other states and
talking about how to export Florida yeah
um because
the thing that I I've always appreciated
about Santa's is that he does a lot from
the gut which means it's not poll tested
it's like this is the right thing to do
yeah um he's helping law enforcement
he's helped teachers he handled covid
well
um and I think that part of this is to
give these Governors
um and other elected officials the
understanding that if you do the right
things for the right reasons things will
happen well right you can't govern
Yourself by a bunch of polls and too
often that's what happens
um and that you have to be willing to
take a hit if you think about cobit with
DeSantis he got hit roughed up a bunch
at the beginning in terms of the testing
centers the first few weeks probably and
my timeline may be a little off but it
wasn't perfect
eight weeks 12 weeks in or whatever it
was people were saying wow look at how
well this is working these centers that
he set up at the different Publix or
what have you um yeah I'm not from here
well you could get monoclonal treatment
right which I got literally the day I
got to Florida I tested positive for
coven when we moved here welcome I went
to a center within an hour I had
monoclonal treatment and the worst thing
that happened to me at the height of it
where my legs hurt for a couple days
right that was it but the point is oh
and then the federal government made it
illegal to do monoclonal right right
right but the point is is that you have
to be willing as a leader to take that
chance and say I know what the right
thing to do is and I think it'll pay off
and it may not pay off 24 hours it may
pay off in 24 days santis has done that
a lot in Florida you've seen Kim
Reynolds in Iowa do that I think Sarah
Sanders is doing a good job I loved your
conversation with her a few weeks back
um but she's doing things that I think
you know you asked her on the thing what
about criminal justice she said you know
what there were some people that weren't
great but I did it because I thought it
was the right thing to do
that's leadership
and I think that we need to see more of
these guys willing to stand up
and say I'll take the hit sometimes it
might not be perfect but I know what the
right thing to do is you know it's true
at a gut level too not just at a policy
level or a success level because you
know DeSantis did this six-week abortion
thing right I'm personally not for that
I think the 15-week thing was fine here
I go to all the Republican events I
never heard anyone complaining about
abortion I thought we had it right I
think for the general it looks way
better if you're at 15 than six just
optically but then I heard him talk
about it like a week or two ago and
basically he was like that's my personal
belief the people voted for me I'm doing
what I think is right and I was like I
have to respect that I may not agree
with the decision but it's also nice to
respect somebody that's in office but
you got to think about it to your point
he did something that he said I might
not get there if you pulled it you might
get everyone to say what you said
initially 15 weeks is great he said you
know what I'm willing to go further
because I I want to stand up and fight
for life I believe the following
he was willing to take a risk for the
right thing
we need more people like that if you sit
back and if his if his calculation was
gosh six I believe in
my gut but gosh it's going to cost me
politically
that's the problem I know that's the
problem and he knows it's look it has to
I don't see any way around it for a jet
it doesn't hurt you in the primary or
Republican primary but my guess is it
does hurt him maybe in the general so
that but that shows guts that's my point
right and I think the general big sense
of it is where he's
done well is that instead of like a lot
of Republicans that have stuck their
head under the chair and said I don't
want to talk about it I hope this
doesn't happen if you're going to sign
it and you believe it go out and fight
for it and he's at least gone out there
and said I believe in this here's why
here's why it makes sense you have to
take these issues head on if they're
going to be controversial if you're
going to fight for it then fight for it
but you can't vote for it or sign it and
then say okay I'm gonna go duck and hide
the Democrats
they politically they know that they
might have something if they out message
you speaking of fight for it so what do
you make of what's going on here with
Trump in descent is because it's it's
getting you know DeSantis hasn't even
announced yet it's obviously happening
at this point uh Trump to me has thrown
in the kitchen sink at this point I mean
going after Florida the way he is like
my you know I like him I voted for him
I'm friends with the kids all of that
stuff that I always say first but I
think his behavior towards DeSantis who
has been by far the best public servant
that we've had in America for the last
three four years
it's it's a real turn off so here here's
and I hear that I I was at uh a big
Trump event probably a month and a half
ago and the message they said when you
talk to the president can you tell him
we love him as President we love
DeSantis as Governor let's not I agree
with that okay
I I don't like red on red I don't like
conservatives we need to support each
other whether it's conservative media
conservative policies get behind things
don't attack whether it's you know even
I keep saying make the case for yourself
there's a case for me to be made for
Trump oh and I've said that too because
I think everyone else runs around and
says I I want Trump policies I want to
America First policy I'm not trying my
point to Trump has been your Trump just
say I am him like I'm not trying to be
him yeah
that being said
so do I would I rather have him making
the case for him DeSantis making the
case from yes that being said it's very
Sun Tzu what Trump is doing which is
prior to the end of the Florida
legislature that the they moved it up
more than I thought they would but end
of April they changed that resign to run
law yeah
Trump knew that his that he desantis's
hands were tied yeah so why not just
keep I mean imagine that you're
literally having to fight somebody
physically and they say for the first
five days of the fight their hands are
tied behind their back you can whack at
him for those five days why wouldn't you
but I don't think it worked I do I mean
look at the poll numbers they did work I
mean Trump went up now maybe but but I
get why he did it he took the free shot
and said I'm gonna take the census
numbers I'm going to bring them down I'm
gonna try to make mine because what he
was trying to do during that time is
convince donors and strategists to say
look this guy can't take a punch look at
his poll numbers go down look at mine go
up do you really want Trump was doing a
Sun Tzu thing which is
don't have the fight you don't have to
have and so if he can get to Santas to
reconsider running which I don't think
he was going to do and say maybe I don't
want to do this well I think that's what
the goal was that was I think it failed
right it did yeah but I think that the
idea was not and if you can't get to
Santa's doing can you show these major
donors and operatives and activists and
Grassroots supporters that's the guy you
want to hit your wagon to here's here's
how we're going to punch him here's how
my pull nerves are going to go up and
his are going to go down that to me was
the strategy is to convince everybody
you really want to do this is the bigger
problem there and I don't mean to make
this fully about Trump understand this
but just sort of broadly about politics
that the more that that sort of stuff
goes on these nonsensical games and all
that stuff it just will keep culling the
field we'll just never get good people
in you know my argument for designs it's
not just that the proof is in the
pudding like he's a good person too it's
fairly obvious and and also there's a
generational shift that I think needs to
happen but that basically if we're if
we're always going to be willing to
throw out every trick in the book and
and treat everything like it is you know
a War in China 2000 years ago that that
will get what we deserve which is a
bunch of sellouts and and yeah
nincompoops basically uh yes and no I
mean so despite all that as we said
desensis is running
so
it didn't work
um and I also think that Trump is you
know I've said this before so I'll say
it again I think he's a unicorn
politically speaking you're not going to
see another Trump so once this cycle is
over I don't put hair alone yeah there
you go uh I don't think you're gonna see
him again no one can pull this off like
he can so I I think there's a uniqueness
to this cycle you're not going to have
another former president the second time
in history that this has happened
that you're going to find somebody that
tries to do this again it's just not so
we're we're in a very unique period in
time I think uh that being said are you
going to see people lay off their
opponents no
uh all right we can talk about
Republicans all day let's do a little a
little bit of Democrats then we'll move
on to some other things I mean fighting
is going to be 82 by the time he
announced uh take office yeah 82. he
obviously has something wrong with him
cognitively everyone knows it everyone
knows that they refuse to talk about it
on mainstream media which gets to what
we were talking about earlier what is
going on with the Democrats I mean are
you do any Democrats talk to you anymore
they don't I will say this for as
I don't know how much Biden gets credit
for this or his team does by putting
Kamala Harris as his vice president
genius it was genius because you're
basically saying you don't want me you
want her okay stick with me folks I mean
I did a video on YouTube that people
should go look at because I believe that
the Democrats have bet the farm if you
go to my YouTube page I lay this out
this is how Kamal Harris becomes
president United States they believe
that Biden can sneak by Trump he sneaks
by whether he steps down or look and
it's not I feel like to your point
people can't talk about let's be honest
the average life expectancy in the
United States for a male a white male
74.2 years old Biden's 80 now okay he's
on borrowed time that might be rude
those are facts so that whether he steps
down he gets removed by his cabinet uh
impeached or something like that he's
not going to service
so it could right
so my point is is that this is the play
but you look at Harris
within her own party she's been rejected
she didn't even make it to the Iowa
caucus's last cycle her poll numbers are
underwater tremendously and then the
next leading people the Pete bootage and
the Gavin newsoms are stuck at six seven
percent they have no bench which is kind
of shocking to me the sense that of all
of these young people that you tell and
you get I mean there's no one that gets
double digits outside of a sitting vice
president
I mean that's that is mind-blowing
um when you think about it sort of tells
you no one even believes this nonsense
like they somehow made the right move
with Biden because it it did accomplish
the goal of getting the presidency but
there's just nobody believes any of the
the ideas or that that their party
doesn't know what they want that no
one's stepping up to the plate They're
all playing the problem is this gets
back to what you were asking question
before this
you have you think about the people I
mentioned whether it's Kamala Harris
people to Gavin Newsom they're not
authentic
they're not out there talking about the
real problems that people are facing and
saying here's what I would do and here's
how I'd lead they're full of talking
points and identity politics but roads
are racist them of course they are I
drove on one in the pothole uh I I got
right out of your way because you're
white it's yeah my privilege I was like
you get out of the way and I'll send the
other people down that that ravage Road
um
but that's the point is that people look
and say they're not this isn't what I
wanted
but the idea that nobody's willing to
step up to the plate in the Democratic
party and be that person that's the
ascent that's the next coming I mean you
think back through history on the
Republican and on the Democratic side it
always hasn't worked out and we had
Scott Walker on our side very very
successful governor in Wisconsin he led
the field for a while kind of faded out
but then other people kind of filled it
in Bill Clinton back in the day you had
John Kerry in that same race in 92 there
were people it was a it was a battle of
the of the Mind who could be the leader
and Clinton making the case then as the
chairman of the DLC the Democratic
Leadership committee that like this more
moderate tone was was what we needed to
embrace in the Democratic party them
fighting it out and then going forward
the idea that they have no one now
they can get double digits
that's I mean that says a lot about
where they're at
um but you just have to look no further
than the Pennsylvania Senate race to
understand why they will elect whoever
you put on the ballot or they'll vote
for him so it's just a question of who
can get you know 13 for my view is in
the next open race in the Democratic
party if Kamal Harris if Biden were to
sneak by and Kamala Harris were to come
in that that seals it right you can't
there no one's going to challenge her uh
in a serious way
but
there there it will be interesting
because whoever sneaks by my guess is is
with a plurality
um but you even look at Robert F Kennedy
he's pulling just shy of 20 they're
doing everything they can to shut that
guy out not only that you got ABC
centering his his speeches
um there you got YouTube censoring pages
but they they don't want anybody as an
alternative to him yeah do you sort of
admire the the ruthlessness of the DNC
at some level I mean well let's say only
one about the Republicans but the
Republicans who didn't who obviously
didn't the machine didn't want Trump
right but they Trump won fair and square
and they let him become the nominee and
eventually the President right the DNC
they're going to do everything they can
to make sure Robert F Kennedy is a
republican to this thing oh yeah and
that that he is not allowed on a debate
stage that he they'll do everything they
can to limit ballot access I keep saying
he should just say I'm a republican now
and at least they'll put him on the
debate stage I don't know what actually
you know what I would love I would love
I would love him to run as an
independent yeah that's where I think
that if you're a republican you want
Robert F Kennedy because he gets on five
six ten States that's a big enough deal
but you don't think that hurts the
Republicans more oh God no you don't
think it gets the people let's say it's
Trump who are just totally Trump
deranged to be like ah not gonna vote
for Trump I'll vote for him so people
who generally argue so people who
generally don't want to when you're
given a binary Choice it's Biden versus
Trump uh then they're forced to pick and
they'll say I don't like Trump but I
hate bid I'm either a gonna sit out
or B I'll hold my nose and vote for
Trump
um if they're not going to vote for
Trump in the first place then you're
just giving them a place to to move
their you know move over to it's not it
actually I think would benefit the party
um to have him the big thing that was
interesting if you look at 2016 versus
2020 the absence of third parties if you
think about Jill Stein
um the libertarian I mean she was the
Green Party candidate but the
libertarian candidate there was at least
15 states where the third party's margin
made a difference in 2016 and that
didn't exist in 2020. what was the
libertarian what was her name again
anyone remember Joe Jorgensen did you
ever interview her poor lady I had her
on the show once she does like an hour
selling me and you know I'm in many ways
I am a Libertarian obviously uh but she
does an hour selling me on everything
and then at the end she made the
Cardinal mistake of saying so are you
going to vote for me and I said no I'm
voting for Trump
it was like I think that was her most
viral moment of the whole time but the
point is that these these third party
people they basically don't exist at
this point well they give you the the
the the again this gets back to you know
this whole idea of like what's important
to understand ballot access is huge yeah
getting on a uh a ballot in a lot of
States if you're not a major party is is
a big deal and so how do the green party
get enough signatures or do well in a
previous election where they they
maintain that ballot access because if
you can't it's either you have to pay a
ton of money you have to get the
signatures which costs a lot of money
and then you're off the ballot and if
you can't get on there then who cares
and you're non-factor the only decisions
that matter the ones that people have to
make and if they don't can't vote for
you then it's a non-issue
when you leave DC now you're still going
to do the show from dc-ish is that fair
to say yeah yeah it's fair I'm not
breaking any news up okay my wife's not
gonna yeah okay okay I don't know I got
kids you know my wife and my kids are
going to be like yes yeah do you ever
fear being too close to just I mean
literally like the proximity to DC and
just the the sort of nepotism and the
whole thing uh can kind of color your
your view of all of this
um so we I'm from Rhode Island a lot of
my family's there we have a place there
uh and so we spend you know a decent
amount of time there I love getting out
I do a lot of things Beyond uh politics
that bring me around the country and so
I getting out and this gets back to what
we talked about earlier where a lot of
these journalists don't getting out and
among people
um I do a lot of I'm on the board two
veterans organizations that uh I bring
me around to places and so I get to see
people that don't care about politics
that's not top of mind they're worried
about you know health care issues making
enough money for their kids or
themselves making a rent payment or
something so you really connect and
understand what's on the top of Mind of
people their concerns safety security
threats from abroad whatever it is that
you you don't necessarily pick up in DC
because everybody's got an agenda uh and
sometimes it's not always uh
it's it's not always genuine you're
telling me people in DC breaking news on
the report we're really going for you
yeah now that you're uh untethered by
yeah the corporation you're really going
oh yeah I'm willing to throw it down
do you have any uh fears of of going
totally independent and not you know
having that structure behind you yeah
um
in in the biggest fear
um is just more of like a personal
nature uh like a health care or I mean
meaning that if you have to go somewhere
for five or six days I mean I know you
you were just in Israel a few weeks ago
uh if
if I got sick what does that mean how do
you sustain yourself
um there are things that you have to
worry about but again
it's a binary choice you know I can sit
and and um I was offered a contract to
say with Newsmax and that was a decision
uh that I said okay do I want the next
two years to continue like this or do I
want to bet on myself
do I believe that I can build something
I've got a great team I've partnered
with a very successful conservative
production company that has done very
very well uh putting shows on so you're
building the home studio the whole no no
no this is this is not a home studio
we're looking at you're going through it
well you can use this in Miami I
appreciate it thank you just in the
winter months yeah But but so we've got
we're building out a studio in DC I do
have a home studio that I can do things
from
um but this is we are we are making
something
Network quality
uh that and again part of this is even
from a set design or whatever I want the
the folks at locals to be part of this
process and say to me hey I I hate when
people sit you know uh too far away from
each other why don't you you know stand
up or I mean I we'll we'll post
questions yeah we'll bring these guys
into this discussion
um and we've got a couple months the
goal is to launch the show in in later
in the summer
um and there's a lot of big things
coming up but but what I want is to use
the time and the opportunity that we
have now to say okay I think I have a
lot of great ideas about how to do this
the production company's been very
successful at doing this but I want to
know what you want what you watch stuff
you've seen you know whether it's
watching you or bongino or or you know
Dinesh a lot of great people and
creators here
um it's about Brown I mean that that
have done great what do you like what do
you don't like and you guys have paved
the way now I can come in from behind
and say tell me what you like about what
you watch what you want differently join
the VIP uh section on my locals Channel
Sean Spicer at locals and and tell me
what is it that you want more of or less
of but that's the beauty of this uh and
I mean there is a little bit of course
there's a bit of a fear but I I think as
a friend of mine said after I made the
announcement he said you know
you've always done this you I've been an
entrepreneur for most of my life I've
sold everything growing up my parents
view was if you want money you go out
and make it and so I sold greeting cards
birthday cakes
um you know you name it I did it washed
car whatever it took because that was
the view if you wanted money no uh you
made it and so if you build it they will
come I mean the idea that I left patreon
and created a subscription model that
ultimately became locals that now
Russell Brand is on and I mean that's
good Nash sold 2 000 mules on and that
euron and Glenn Greenwald and Crowder
and all these guys it's like I guess if
you actually do something worthwhile
then people show up and and so for me
that was it like I said I'm not being uh
patronizing but I truly do believe that
when you watch people do this and you
say okay
in my own way I'm not Dave Rubin I'm not
Dinesh I'm not you know but but I think
I have something to offer
um
and and so if I can bring people into
this process go out and do this every
day and say okay the Durham report just
dropped or uh this just happened on
Capitol Hill or Trump said this and
DeSantis went this way why are they
doing that
um I mean in this like I said at the
outset there everybody's got their skill
and their insight into something that
they've done personally or that God's
given them the skill to do I I know
politics and party rules like the back
of my hand I mean
for some people that's probably dorky
but I love it and so to be able to say
well here's the problem you know rule
seven of the RNC rules doesn't permit
the following it's not about ex liking
it or disliking it's about explaining it
you know it's literally like when you're
watching uh a baseball game and saying
that's a foul ball you may say it's a
great hit and it went really really far
but it was outside the Baseline and it
doesn't count so it's understanding the
rules of the game that I think is
important as we head into this
unbelievable historic and consequential
election I ask everybody some version of
this question politicians and media
people are you worried that the more
that we go in this independent route
that they'll be okay the people that
watch Spicer and okay that's where
they're getting their truth from the
people that watch Ruben they're getting
their truth there people watch Megan
they're getting it there and that
ultimately even though our truths are
roughly the same thing but you do that
with all the different voices out there
that we're going to just end up
completely living on other planets well
we'll all be on Earth but other
intellectual planets maybe we're there
already well the thing is I mean you
listed off your example I don't think
that my truth is that different from
your truth no no so that wasn't the best
thing no no no what I'm saying is it's
like within sure yeah
what the problem is
part of the reason this Evolution has
occurred is because the ABCs and NBCS
and cbs's for a long time were the only
options you had you know when I grew up
you literally stood up turned to dial
and that's all you got you you didn't
even have the box with the wire listen
I'll tell you this it was like 15 years
after cable came out before my parents
even caved and I think that it's like
they were required to uh they were like
you'll get up and turn the channel yeah
so
this idea that this happened because
they didn't do their job yeah
um and they're not seeing stories and
they're watching issues happen and
saying we hear that this is happening I
see it with my own eyes and no one on
these big channels is talking about it
and so I watched uh you know a couple
weeks ago we saw this thing uh where
that gentleman
uh held back uh the the person on the
subway and all of the media kept saying
uh this Marine veteran killed uh a
homeless uh man on the subway it's like
okay that's not exactly how it went down
and the media keeps framing stories
they've lost us it's not like
Independent Media just exists it went
out and said let's try to find people
and make this a big marketing exercise
people said I don't like what I'm seeing
give me something new and people like
you and Russell Brandon everyone said
great I will bring it to you and people
said I like that but it also doesn't
mean that that's the only place they're
getting it from I would encourage people
go I want you go watch ABC News tonight
go watch uh or listen to an NPR segment
because you're gonna see what you don't
get what news right
you know that well that's MSNBC right
yeah they're all drunk yeah they have to
be drunk they're just stupid uh
problem is they that they created this
problem yeah they created a void in the
market that was filled and
um so great I'll help fill it in
summation Sean you're telling me I
cannot promote this vehicle properly
because it doesn't have a name can I
even is it Sean spicer.locals.com yes so
that at least it is yeah we just don't
know the name of the uh if you join the
VIP section Dave I can get you I can get
you in you can get me in for a deal uh
let's see what I can do I mean I think
we're it's like four bucks a month five
bucks a month come on this that's to be
two months free with an annual
subscription
listen I got a kid I got kids
um look
I think part of this is that that's the
beauty of this let's let's do this
together yeah um tell me what's what's
going on but join be part of this and uh
I think that's the fun part of it
um and then over the course of the next
several months we'll go to places we'll
talk to people we'll bring up issues
that I don't think you'll see anywhere
else and again the thing that's so
beautiful about this is
I I think between the White House
military you know time on Capitol Hill
campaigns I can show stuff to you that
frankly no one else on television or
even on the internet does I mean there's
just no one I mean when I left the RNC
after six years I think I had been the
longest serving person in that in that
post in modern history at least
um so the idea of being able to see
multiple cycles and to say this is what
went wrong once this is how it got
corrected these are the reasons the
rules got changed are all really
important to understand the world that
we live in and more importantly how we
can change it if you don't know how to
change it yelling at the wall or the
television or your screen or your tablet
isn't going to do anything but I think
what we saw during covid
was that people said I don't like what
I'm seeing I don't like what my kids
learning I'm willing to go out and
change things all willing to you know
fight for it to join a school board to
show up at a PTA meeting and change
occurred and I think that's kind of what
we want to offer is how do we go out and
make things a better place because I
don't like where things are going right
now in terms of the woke culture
immigration culture the threats that
we're facing both from China and abroad
I I so I want to give people the tools
and say Here's how you can actually make
a difference John I am but a humble
independent content creator but you as a
former cable news guy I'm going to give
you a chance to look directly in the
camera and tell the people where to go
to end this program Dave Reuben's local
audience please join me on this journey
help me be successful as successful if
not more than Dave uh I thank you for
allowing me to be here and please join
my locals Community Sean Spicer locals
and uh and then become a VIP member and
make this your show as much as mine
thank you very much
appreciate your support and I look
forward to your wait we're not both and
communication yeah all right if you're
looking for more uncensored opinions
from today's thought leaders check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a wide variety
of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell